in this video i will explain you the
commonalities and differences between
the correlation regression and the
causality
as you already know from our video on
correlation correlation analysis
examines the relationship of variables
one question might be
is there a correlation between the age
at which a child speaks his or her first
sentences
and later school success
the correlation analysis shows the two
characteristics are interrelated
now it could be investigated whether one
variable can be used to predict the
other one
thus school success should be predicted
by the age at which a child speaks his
or her first sentences
using regression
if there is a correlation between the
age at which a child speaks his or her
first sentences and later school success
we can even speak of a causal
relationship in this case
for example that the age at which a
child speaks his first sentences
influences later school success
in this case it is very easy because we
have a temporal separation it is clear
that later school success cannot
influence the age at which a child
speaks his or her first sentences
but beware it's not always that easy
for this we look at the next example
let's say at the end of the school time
you make an intelligence test with
pupils and ask them about their high
school grade after you have done your
survey
and analyze the data
it will surely turn out that there is a
correlation between intelligence and the
high school grade
but now comes the big question mark
is there a causal relationship
of course we could now simply set up a
regression model and define intelligence
as an independent variable
and high school grade as a dependent
variable
and predict the high school grade with
intelligence
but with that
we have not yet proven causality
but first let's look at the question
what does causality exactly mean
causality means that there is a clear
cause effect relationship between two
variables
a common mistake in the interpretation
of statistics is that when a correlation
exists a causality isn't feared
here i have a suitable example for you
the american statistician daryl half
found a negative correlation between the
number of headlines and the body
temperature of the inhabitants of a
group of islands a negative correlation
means that people with many lies
generally have a lower body temperature
than people with few lies
the inhabitants of the island have
concluded that since lies reduce fever
they are good for health
so this would mean that lies have an
influence on the body temperature
but in reality the causality is the
other way around in an experiment it
could be proven that high fever drives
away the lies
so the high temperature
is the cause and not the effect
therefore we cannot speak of a causal
relationship just because there is a
correlation
for causality there are exact
preconditions
but what are the conditions for
causality
when can we speak of a causal
relationship
there are two requirements for causality
first there is a significant
relationship that is a significant
correlation
this precondition is of course easy to
test
we simply take the correlation
coefficient and check
if it is significantly different from
zero
the second condition can be satisfied in
two ways
first it is satisfied if there is a
temporal ordering of the variables
so variable a was collected temporally
before
variable b
furthermore the second condition can be
fulfilled
if there is a theoretically founded and
plausible theory in which direction the
causal relationship goes
if none of the two is true for example
there is neither a temporal order nor
can the causality be justified by a
well-founded theory then we can only
speak of a relationship but never of
causality for example it cannot be said
that variable e influences variable b or
vice versa
let's take a look at our example again
in the first example where the question
is whether the age at which a child
speaks the first sentences influences
later school success
there is clearly a temporal component
the measurement of when the first
sentences are spoken
is clearly before the measurement of
later school success
the relationship cannot be the other way
around
if one has a great school success by a
lot of tutoring this has of course no
influence on when the first sentences
are spoken
on the other hand if we measure
intelligence and the high school average
at the same time
we do not have this temporal component
in order to be able to make a statement
here
there must be a well-founded theory of
which variable influences which
if there is not no statement about
causality can be made
there is certainly a high correlation
between intelligence and high school
grade
but it could also be that people who
study a lot have good grades and have
acquired the knowledge to do well in an
intelligence test
so the intelligence and the high school
grade were determined at the same time
of course you can avoid this by taking
the intelligence test before school
starts
then you can be sure that the school had
no influence on the intelligence test
this of course requires a lot of time
and effort
because you get the results many years
later and the same people have to be
interviewed at two different times
now you have a good overview of what
causality means and we can go into more
detail about regression
check out my video on simple and
multiple linear regression for that
i look forward to seeing you back in a
bit
you